okay so godric the grafted definitely on
the higher scale difficulty of the
bosses that you're going to experience
up to this point in the game again
depending on where you do go you can go
anywhere you want but if you do end up
facing godric you're probably in for a
bad time and let me tell you all right
now godric is not that bad for one
simple reason he has the biggest towels
i've ever seen in any boss in any souls
game ever he has the longest load ups
and the biggest attacks that you can
easily dodge all you have to do is kind
of keep your medium-sized distance and
then he will do the attacks you want so
you can get some free hits in i'll be
going over every attack pattern during
the video so if you do enjoy this video
and learned something please give it a
like subscribe and make sure to go and
check out our twitch channel we're going
to be streaming this game for months and
months and months learning every nook
and cranny this game has to offer i'd
really appreciate it and this is how you
beat godric the golden
let's get it
we are definitely gonna die
how the
what the [ __ ]
this is so cool
whoa
okay okay okay i gotta eat my green
beans for this one bro i mean [ __ ] we
gotta go back to our scythe out imagine
can't tell what arm's gonna [ __ ] hit
me
definitely more
he's a roly poly
he's doing different attacks than before
how do you dodge that i think i have to
roll at a specific time
dude one got stuck
i love the music
didn't reach
he's so gross
he's got some pretty wicked tells
still learning obviously
i kind of want him to do that attack
pretty easy dodge
bang
bang
that's a hit
i need you off the stairs my guy
i shouldn't have tried it that was
stupid
figuring him out though
he's got some wicked tells
like he's uh
he really telegraphs what he's about to
do we can figure this guy out 100
yep we want him to do the wendy attack
so that he can go up into the air
that one's a tough dodge
um i didn't see that coming my bad
yep the windy attack
good
then you'll roll and jump and then we
get two free hits in uh this is just the
swipe to swipe
that's fine
it's a five combo i didn't realize that
till now
okay so wind he'll roll
and jump
big hits
one hit two swipe
bang bang
yep
one more yep i'm telling you guys it
looks bad right now but we're gonna
figure this guy out pretty quick this is
the earthquake
yeah see that's what i was afraid of
moving in too fast so i get more hits in
i just don't need to i think one's fine
but two is possible
that's just not a time to attack when he
does that big ass wind-up it's really
not
it seems like it but it's not i need to
remember that
no shot
uh oh
oh
okay
second phase has a a cutscene
did he just cut off his arm
oh my god
truest of dragons
lend me thy strength
oh my god it's actually gonna work okay
of course yeah we're playing we're
playing a souls game here of course that
works
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that's awesome oh my god
i don't have any more fp
okay that reaches a very
far distance
we gotta i frame through the fire we got
that figured out
do you release
no jump
that's harder to dodge
now
all right now we got to figure out phase
two
iframe
i dodged too early
[ __ ]
let's learn the attacks
whoa
that's a grab
no idea how you dodged this what do i do
about this
what the [ __ ]
i have no idea what to do about that
i don't know what these do but let's do
them
so that was a triple earthquake
the fire still hits from behind
oh my god
we'll take it
i think you just got to run away
see it coming and run i don't know
damn that'll be nope you didn't do three
what
roly-poly
that load up oh my god
insane
cool with that
okay i'm learning stage two isn't as bad
as i thought
that's gonna be a three
still [ __ ] hit me
i don't know what this does well let's
let's rock it in
might as well [ __ ] use it man let's
just run okay running works there
we like this this is what we want
never mind
it's not what we wanted
we did a huge bleed on them too
[Music]
iframe through the fire
that'd be a wicked bad grab
no idea what he's doing
three earthquake
okay this is the uh yup just run
still got hit
cringe
he didn't go for the three
come on don't throw [ __ ] at me don't
throw [ __ ] at me thank you
let's go
i'm a god
not that bad
that boss is not that hard
but he's he's fun
oh my god i can't believe i did that
dude halfway through that second stage i
was like there's no [ __ ] shot i can
do this and i just kept hitting bro i
kept dodging he he has the longest pills
i've ever seen in a boss fight in dark
souls so once you learn his tells like
okay he's gonna do this then you know
what to do you know what the dodge he
doesn't have that many moves so it's not
that bad how long do you think that took
me chat like 30 minutes to beat that
boss i think we're just killing it right
now man we're just killing it
i have no health too look at my health
there ain't nothing there dog
oh my god
let's see what's in here